[Music]
that describes correct form as much as
where to move do you understand okay so
in Chico the grounding vector cuts
through your feet not through your
kneecaps okay so when you ground through
your knees there's really no stabilizing
energy there because the kneecap can
move do you understand that then the
kneecap move your kneecap and you're
gonna see oh yeah it's meant to float
like that do you see that so when you go
to brace for example on this second move
you're here and you're bracing on this
knee
it gives
and you're starting to diminish the
cartilage between the kneecap and the
femur you just grind it away got it and
that's not correct for the grounding
vector is along your hot up and that's
going to be my feet
do you understand the grounding vector
is not at my kneecap nor between my feet
of my kneecap somewhere here
do you understand so when he's when he's
pushing it's not that cheese
I'm drowning on my knees I'm grounding
on my feet you see so he's pushing it's
my feet which is why I don't need my
kneecaps push you see he's not knocking
me down do you understand
so he's pushy and I can you push really
hard
he's just grounded you can stand up just
ground me grounding on my feet just like
here do you understand
okay so don't get greedy you're here
and then you're going to push on that
knee it's on your feet you'll feet do it
oh here do you understand not this knee
cap okay
so throughout your technique you don't
want your kneecap to float across your
femur so I don't do it when I'm bracing
and I don't do it when I she go
so when you cheat go somebody go like
this you see that okay so I can spin on
my the can't move it laterally across
the mount because it will move laterally
across my femur so the first move this
is the tendency you go like this you see
that like you just rolled your kneecap
the first move just here you see no
rolling I'm here I turn this face onto
my feet
you see
oh okay now what you get it back on my
feet because this has a follow-up I have
to just now a moment the angle you see
now when I come in I can only rotate on
this meat you see see how turning on the
knee and down he goes around with me on
the second one what do you think I'm
going to do here
rotate on to me do you see rotate on
with you but this is what we have in
instead knee bracing folding kneecap
rotated he goes up kneecap coming in
slide you see ice with it coming around
slid it you're just injuring your
stumps and you're not learning the art
why do I have to slide this because I'm
pulling him I'm just pulling him that's
not the art he comes up I'm fishing here
you see now
his are supposed to go after you oh oh
he goes underneath underneath not push
away he stays under me watch you see I'm
just letting I'm being nice for training
pivot on that need we're done inside the
circles boom adjust for the new angle
feet rotate whoa rotate done I can't get
it gone linear projection living here
what up at the end of the line nope the
end of the line to get young world
what was the opposite of a linear I'm
Alexis a turn a circle you get it
there's the live your life ends circle
here comes a linear line what do you
think comes at the end circle okay when
they do that and circular begins for
circular as linear begins
oh my job speech linear vertical linear
circle okay
bring them around you into you do you
still have some turn to do stop you
don't understand it means you have turn
going counterclockwise to finish there
you go
then you're gonna pivot on that knee the
inside knee and you're going to turn
bring your feet underneath you because
the fleet are the grounding vector know
you got the legs all checked out do that
same hand you go to pivot on the left
knee left kneecap good step back out of
the way try it again
boom good and you're on your feet not
your knee then on your feet for Jack and
then you're gonna bring him around
you're gonna enter and bring him around
you all the way you're not enough your
feet aren't under you then enter and
push him around
don't drag that right kneecap did you
see that there you got too much linear
down and around don't drag that knee you
drag the left kneecap I turn inside
that's as far as I can go the extra
balance that you want
don't go linearly you're gonna slide
that take up the her body you like she's
not laying down you get it so you try to
lay her down bring her around she laid
down and I didn't slide that kneecap
same thing goes here where this rotation
ends where does it end by the foot
coming in the back foot you see that
that's the end of the technique that's
where the technique ants won't turn back
up whoa on my feet adjust for the feet
rotate in how far can you rotate that's
the question this leg comes back in the
night that's all I can rotate she laid
out come around again
[Music]
Oh
I need so that I meet in this leg
rotates that's all I can do
then first slack gets taken up on the
circle not me going forward on the
circle you see I'm gonna rotate again
don't slide out this time this foot
comes in you see down so this is the
problem your sheet going and you're
sliding the patella you see why because
you're trying to lengthen the body
lengthen it on the curve not the obvious
lengthening of their spine rotate their
spine you get it if you have a string
and you want to lengthen that string you
can pull one end away from the other or
you can create a spool and wind it that
string is not a cop anymore you get it
that's what we're trying to do
you're on your kneecaps
you didn't just the left foot the left
knee that's it you're gonna do big
rotation bring the left foot around all
the way more bring him around you around
you bore no he doesn't do it you do it
to him
where does your jack enough yes bring
that leave the foot around ring yes you
slid the inside of your right patella no
step out and rotate on that knee all the
way all the way there you go
adjust for the foot vector wrong bring
them around you bring that foot around
the foot the back foot does the rotation
then up and the back foot does the
rotation push him push him he rotated
but you left him there you disconnected
your hands from your hip there you go
bring it around your foots not under you
so kids go under me okay pins go
underneath he's under me you see down
here so I'm gonna here see hospital
longer me I can't have them push it away
from me even this movie just so I take
this in space here then he's gonna go
under me look look same exact position
you see what you guys hear me whine it's
pushing away even though you think I
turned a little but do you see that you
don't like that you see so what do you
do you can't check to him why do you
push them look what's happening
you say oh you can stop it right here
do you get it can't do that here
he can get up under me look is it still
under me I'll show you you see the whole
time
you can't keep breaking it it's under me
and only the curve does that okay you're
like gonna give it here
no you don't do you understand that
elbow has to stay underneath can he lift
his elbow lift your hardest he's naughty
cat Lynch as though lifted your hardest
top left to know you could do anything
with this with that as long as he's
under you okay so don't let this space
make you ruin your patella okay oh and
your technique let's go don't push it
away bring your knee bring your weight
onto that
ETV get on to that point and we give it
on that point in dirt single to the
point the other knees buy it but I'm not
turning on okay cuz it's gonna step like
the other technique where I adjust with
the Pope you know not where's my weight
oh my feet oh not my knees comes around
me single pivot point boom boom single
pivot point
oh my feet I don't know my knees on to
my feet Oh in dirt bring your other knee
off the ground you see don't do this
come around the other side don't go like
this you see that did you guys see that
I'm dragging the patella in turn pick it
up the knee boom give it Oh onto the
feet not to me whoa
one minute feet look at the difference
knees watch feet you see your balance
boom
[Music]
stop exaggerating this part you can see
what it is and we don't do a Sheila ten
count on the second move like the second
move is chiton you just open the knee
like you did on the second move of ikki
oh you just did
it's stay on your feet don't go to your
knees better
okay so that's the footwork but you're
not doing the technique
she shouldn't be standing still until
you complete the footwork she's losing
her balance with the footwork okay go
that's it balance good let's go pick
you're good don't get greedy stay on
your feet so you do a Koki projection
that's better
nope wrong TV yeah I'd go over into
right but rather bring her in bring her
in there you go
no yes well we don't pick up the foot on
the last the last technique I'm just
doing tighten not as she doe tank on
there you slid your kneecap
[Music]
okay so now I don't exaggerate the new
movement so when I coming around here I
was picking up that knees and you can
see okay the I should feel the
resistance of the mat and it's going to
tell me how much I need to pick it up
you get it just like you you're pushing
you're telling me we're about hot needs
to go for the technique you get it so
don't pick it up any more than you have
to how much the minimum you have to pick
up the knee so that what doesn't know
the minimum I have to take the knee up
off the knot so I don't drag my kneecap
do you see that so when you guys winter
I was exaggerating this turn you see how
much it's up don't know just pick it up
enough that it's not sliding the kneecap
so when I when I in turn I'm here boom
same thing every all the moves the
kneecaps just mellow out just fine but
it doesn't come up so you probably can't
tell that my knee
but it's not just hovering over it okay
if I feel their kneecaps start to move
what do I have to do
raise it okay but I don't raise it so
high that now my balance and posture is
compromised
all right let's go I'm very chic oh
right how far can this be you can talk
where you don't drag that me it's up to
where I don't drag the patella do you
see that so that's it right but if I go
to put this down what's gonna happen
it's gonna drag the patella okay so I'm
gonna go one that's it
that's all I got got it okay all your
all your movements is nothing more than
a line the line adds and the extra slack
that you want to take up is on the curve
you get that so where the line ends the
circle begins and where the circle is
the new line begins I can't
now take that model and start sliding it
sagittal II across this mat them to tell
us going to get injured okay if I'm
doing standing it's the same thing he
that's where my step goes he has to go
around me I can't go back up just a
little further dirty you've seen because
that's gonna injure the patella at the
bottom this is where I am he didn't fall
enough he has to go around me okay you
got it
I can only use that model circle line
line circle got it
okay stop sliding your patella on the
map and you won't be doing cye Raza as
long as me okay